cbs news meteorologist and climate
specialist that's jeff baradelli is here
now with what these changing weather
systems mean for the rest of the country
not just in terms of the storms which we
see are devastating but also the heat
jeff good morning to you because this
heat is brutal yeah good morning guys
and good morning everyone so it is not
just the west that we have heat problems
it's the deep south as well so let's go
to the weather wall and expand this to
show you first of all take a look at
what's happening in louisiana so we have
heat we have humidity feels like
temperatures in the mid 90s to near 100
degrees without power a dangerous
situation also dangerous in the west
once again another heat dome across the
west for the next several days we're
going to see record high temperatures
could be as many as 50 or 60 in the west
in fact we could hit 110 degrees in the
valleys of california that is not good
news for firefighters who are fighting
over 60 fires in the west this is the
bridge fire it's a small fire 500 people
have had to evacuate because of this but
we have much bigger fires in fact the
dixie fire 900 000 acres another 100 000
acres it will become the largest fire in
california history beating you guessed
it last year's fires so this is not a
coincidence
this is climate change why are we seeing
all these really really big fires well
let's bring this up and send it on over
to the big weather wall and talk about
exactly what's going on right now so
notice this upward trend fire weather
days are increasing because we have a
lot more heat a lot more dry conditions
across the west and now we have a
drought and that drought exponentially
we see an exponential increase in fires
the intensity of fires the acres burned
because of extra dryness so a little
more dryness a little more heat causes
an exponential increase so that's likely
to continue in the future as long as we
keep warming the climate and as we head
through the next couple of months cold
fronts will move in cold fronts are good
it cools it down but it also dries it
out and the wind is bad we're getting
into peak wind season in the west santa
ana winds diablo winds that means
hurricane force wind gusts across the
west and what that means is things are
going to become more complicated for
firefighters unfortunately before things
get more simpler over the next few
months guys man jeff i'm looking at the
fires on looking at the rain i'm
thinking about people like amitamenti
who you get heavy rain do you have to
worry now every time that you could
possibly die in your own homes this is
mind-boggling to me we have to really
get prepared for climate change as you
can see it's ramping up very fast it's a
great great information uh tough
situation for so many people in this
country but we're also very excited to
see that map jump from that map you like
that i get my technology is how i get my
cardio every day from well done jeff
well done jeff well done thank you very
much